[Music]
look cool this is getting real about her
man Ashton and his marriage to Demi
I married a divorcee who is he married
to Demi Moore yeah like a normal real
yeah relationship it's like three kids
they were raising there was a gun or
Mille life speaking publicly for the
first time about Ashton's first wife on
comedian Marc Maron's podcast Mila also
says Ashton cherished being a stepdad to
Damis three daughters with Bruce Willis
he was younger but he you know he still
have a relationship with him mmm
Mila has been getting candid about life
with Ashton all over the country
promoting her new comedy the spy who
dumped me the two of course were friends
first playing a couple on that 70s show
I married my boyfriend in the show do
you think he was cute then by the way my
husband what am I supposed to say yes
last night on Fallon she described their
extremely unconventional honeymoon in an
RV we also went honeymooning with my
in-laws and my wonderful beautiful
mother-in-law picked the RV parks that
we were staying in let me tell you an RV
park
with two prisons okay yes guys that is
where our RV trip ended I quit
[Music]